Right? Our stream is live.
Welcome. I guess it's week five now. So,
this is exam week.
Uh so, today we're going to be talking
about some new material and then the
latter half of today is going to cover
whatever your questions are
uh in in advance of the exam.
So, we'll be doing maybe 45 or 50
minutes of new material take our
10-minute break as usual.
And then the rest of the time will be
your questions. So, I'm going to do my
very best to limit the new material to
just the first half of of the class
period.
So, let's jump right in.
So, on the agenda today
if you recall from last time we began
talking just very briefly about the the
notion of replication of data
replication. So, we're going to talk
about
reasons to do replication.
And then we're going to talk today about
two replication techniques.
And these are both techniques that give
you
uh what's called strong consistency. So,
we're going to talk informally
about what strong consistency means.
And then the two techniques that we're
going to look at are called
primary backup replication
and chain replication.
And that's going to lead us into the
last thing that I want to talk about
today, which is
latency and
throughput.
And then
all the rest of the time that we have
left will be after our break we're going
to do
exam review.
And logistics. So, I'll talk a little
bit about exam logistics.
But this exam review part will be
basically whatever questions you want to
ask.
Okay.
So, let's get started.
So,
we started talking last time a little
bit about this notion of of reasons to
do replication.
Um and we we talked about how
replication involves making copies of
data.
So,
let's talk a little bit about why why we
do this. So,
it's fairly obvious
already that if you just have one
process
and now that process
has some events on it and maybe it has
some process local memory, like it knows
that X is three.
If that process crashes and that's the
only process that knows that
information, that has that state then
we're in trouble.
Right? Because then
our data is lost.
So,
it's helpful to have another copy.
We can replicate this thing with all its
state.
So, mitigating data loss is one reason
to do this.
And it's possibly the most important
reason. Now, if one of these crashes,
now this fact that X is three isn't
lost. But
are there other reasons why you would
want another copy of a process aside
from fault tolerance?
What do you think?
Performance. Okay, can you go into a
little bit more detail about about that?
Yeah, so some people are making good
suggestions here. Faster response time.
Yeah. So,
if I'm here in Santa Cruz and I want to
ask what the value of X is in this
key-value store
um
and maybe this one is running uh
on a machine in Australia.
And maybe this one is running on a
machine in a data center in Sunnyvale
just down the road.
It's probably going to be faster to make
the request to the one that's closer to
me physically.
It's not necessarily guaranteed, right?
But, you know, this is the internet.
Everything's asynchronous. No promises,
but it's awfully likely that the machine
that's physically closer to me is the
one that I'm going to hear from faster.
So, one thing that you can do is make a
bunch of replicas, put them in different
places around the world
and then they'll be close to the clients
that need them.
So, one other reason that we can put
down here is data locality.
So, this means having the data close to
the clients that need it.
Other reasons to do replication.
Good. Yeah, somebody just mentioned also
distributes the load on the machines.
Yeah. It divides up the work.
So, if we have just one machine, if
we're getting a lot of requests
say for the value of one particular key
and we're having a hard time handling
them all with one machine, it might make
a lot of sense to have another machine
to take some of the burden off.
So, these are all reasons to do
replication.
What are the downsides of doing
replication?
Sure, okay. A couple of people mentioned
higher costs. Yeah. Yeah, one reason is
it's expensive. You have to have more
machines, right? You either have to buy
them or you have to rent them from
Amazon or Google
or some other cloud computing service.
So,
it's going to cost more money to
replicate. And it's kind of it's it's
different from, you know, we talked
about how
fault tolerance often involves making
copies. Well, if you want to make a copy
of a message to ensure that it's
delivered, right? We talked about how
reliable message delivery sometimes
involves sending a message more than
once, right? But with that, you can kind
of do it in a um
pay-as-you-go way in the sense that if a
message isn't received, you can send it
again. So, you don't have to pay the
upfront cost of sending the message
multiple times. With this,
if you wait until the machine has
crashed before you get another machine,
then you're in trouble. So, with
replication, you have to pay the upfront
cost of having the different copies and
you may not even need the second copy,
but you um but you have to have that
investment. So, it's expensive.
What are the other downsides?
Yeah, a couple of people mentioned. One
person said inconsistency. Yep. Yep.
So, this is I think the much bigger
downside of replication.
If you have two copies
you have to keep them consistent. And
this can be really complicated.
Especially if they can crash, right?
Which was the reason that we wanted to
have replication in the first place
because we want to prevent data loss in
case of a crash. But if these two copies
are running, we have to make sure that
they both stay up to date with each
other.
So, consistency can be complicated
especially if they can crash, which was
a reason that we wanted to do
replication in the first place.
And especially if they're physically far
apart, which was another reason we
wanted to do replication. This idea of
having geo-distributed copies of our
data so that the copies can be close to
whichever clients need them.
And it's also hard if they're both
serving requests. It's also harder to
keep them them consistent if they're
both serving requests, which was yet
another reason why we wanted to do
replication.
So,
another downside of replication, if you
want to call it that, an unavoidable
trade-off that you have to make with
replication is not only is it more
expensive than only having one copy, but
you have to keep the copies consistent.
I'm going to put often here
because it turns out
that
a fair amount of the time you can get
away without keeping the regular the
replicas entirely consistent.
So, I'm going to put this in a box
because that's a notion that we're going
to come back to later in the course.
We're going to talk about when can you
get away with not keeping the replicas
consistent? Because it turns out that a
lot of the time
something weaker than keeping the
replicas perfectly consistent is good
enough.
However, today we're going to be talking
about keeping the replicas perfectly in
sync with each other and we'll be a
little more specific about what that
means.
Okay, so
now that we've kind of motivated the
need for replication and the fact that
replication involves this trade-off
uh let's start talking about
protocols for doing replication. Well,
first let me define this notion of
what's called strong consistency.
So
this is going to be an informal
definition
because
a formal definition is honestly quite
tedious and what I really want is to
give you a more intuitive notion of what
it means for replicas to be consistent.
And we don't need all the math and all
of the formalism to give you that
intuitive idea.
So, here's the informal definition of
what we want.
We're going to say
a replicated storage system
is strongly consistent
if clients
cannot tell
that the data is replicated.
So, the easy way of course to have
strong consistency is to just have one
copy, right?
But as we just talked about, there are
lots of reasons to want to have more
than one copy.
So
let's talk a little bit about how this
is done.
Before I do that, you know, there's
another idea that I want to discuss, but
I don't know if I'm going to have time
for it. So, let me just jump right into
replication protocols and then we'll
come back to this other idea that I'd
like to discuss just in just in case
there's not enough time. I'd like to
make sure to get the protocols out of
the way.
So, we're going to talk about
a protocol that does strongly consistent
replication.
And it's called primary backup
This is a protocol that is a strongly
consistent replication protocol. So, it
gives you this property that clients
can't tell that the data is replicated.
So, it works like this.
You pick a particular replica, a
particular process, and I'm going to
call it P
to be the primary.
So, P stands for primary here.
And then all of the other replicas are
considered backups.
So, let's say that we have one primary
and let's say that we have uh three
backups.
And the idea is that clients will only
interact with the primary.
So, here's a client over here.
Let's say that the client wants to do a
write.
So, let's stick with our
example and pretend that this is a
key-value store. So, let's say that the
client is uh
uh trying to write to the key-value
store and wants to set a particular key
to a particular value. So, let's say the
client wants to write
let's set X to three.
That write is going to first go to the
primary.
When the primary gets a write from a
client
the first thing it's going to do is
broadcast that write to all the backups.
The backups are then going to send an
acknowledgement to the primary.
So, I'll do that in different color here
I think to make it a little more
readable.
Let's see if blue looks different enough
from
black.
I'll do it dotted lines as well to make
sure that it looks different.
So, the backups are all going to send an
acknowledgement to the primary. So, this
message
that the primary sends out
says set X to three.
At the point when all of the backups
have acknowledged the primary
then at that point the primary can tell
the client
that the write succeeded.
So, at that point
after the primary has acknowledged the
write to the client
at that point the primary is actually
allowed to deliver the write to itself.
So, the backups all delivered the write
to themselves immediately after getting
it. But the primary only delivers the
write to itself after it's gotten
acknowledgements from all the backups
that it broadcast to.
We call that point right there, the
point at which the primary has gotten
acknowledgements from all of the backups
and then delivered the write to itself.
We call that point
the commit point
of that write.
And then it can acknowledge the client,
tell the client, "Okay
that write happened."
So, that's how writes work. What about
reads? What do you think the client is
going to do when it wants to read the
value of X?
Mhm.
Interesting. Yeah, pick the closest
server
is the suggestion in chat. So
indeed, picking the closest server would
help you get that property that we
talked about earlier, that data locality
property.
Turns out that primary backup is really
not very good at giving you data
locality.
Because with primary backup you end up
doing something else. Instead with
primary backup
the client only interacts with the
primary. So, the client is just going to
ask its question right here.
Maybe the client wants to know what X is
now.
And the primary will tell it.
So, there's no need for a read to be
broadcast to the other replicas because
the primary already knows
what it is, already knows what to tell
the client.
However, the question kind of
anticipates
this issue with primary backup
replication, right? Because it doesn't
give us that property that we thought
was so good that property of data
locality. Instead, the client's only
talking to this one server, this one
primary.
Why does it work this way?
Why would it not be okay
for the client to just go and ask, let's
say
B2.
Why couldn't the client just go ask B2
or B1 or any of these?
Yeah, good point.
The write might have there might have
been another write that's gotten to one
of these backups, but hasn't
committed on the primary yet. So, let's
say another write happened.
Let's say the client wrote
this.
So, here the client is updating the
value of X.
Once again, that has to get broadcasted
out.
And those have to get acknowledged as
well.
So,
what would happen if, let's say,
this one acknowledged.
If the client were to go ahead and read
from B1 at this point,
maybe the right got here,
but the right hasn't committed on the
primary yet. So, the primary still
thinks that X is three. And in fact,
the client hasn't gotten any
acknowledgement yet that X is three. So,
the client All the client knows right
now is
they've set X to three,
then they've set X to four, then they
got an acknowledgement of the right that
X was three, right?
So, they haven't gotten any
acknowledgement of this right
the second right yet.
So, as far as the client is concerned,
they don't even know if this right got
to the primary because they haven't
gotten an ack yet. So,
this right as far as the client is
concerned, this right can't really be
said to have completed until they get an
acknowledgement.
We certainly don't want the client to
read any rights that haven't completed.
And that's what could happen if we
allowed the client to read from backups.
They could read something that hadn't
committed yet.
And that's why the rights and reads all
have to go through the primary here when
you're using this primary backup scheme.
Now,
you might ask, well,
that sucks, right? That doesn't give us
the data locality that I that we were
talking about just a minute ago. And I
would agree,
yeah,
does suck.
Maybe we can do better.
So,
what are the drawbacks to this approach?
Well, the primary is a kind of a
bottleneck, right?
We listed three reasons for wanting to
do replication. So, there was fault
tolerance, there was dividing up the
work, and there was locality. So, how
does how does primary backup do on each
of these things? Well, fault tolerance,
it's doing pretty well, right? We have
backup copies.
And because the right doesn't commit
here until it's already reached
everywhere else,
let's say that the primary crashed.
Let's say that the primary crashed
before the commit point of a right.
Then,
or let's say that it crashed um
yeah, let's say that it Let's say that
the primary crashed um
at some point
in here. Um
you know that that right has already
committed or that right has already been
delivered on all of the backups. So, the
backups are always going to be at least
as far ahead as the primary in terms of
how many rights they've delivered.
So, since the backups are always at
least as far ahead,
if the primary crashes, we don't lose
data.
So, we're in pretty good shape as far as
fault tolerance is concerned.
But as far as those other things that we
hoped to have,
data locality
and um
dividing up the work,
primary backup replication is
not so good.
Questions about that?
Okay, so
natural question to ask is, can we do
better than this? Can we make it so that
the primary doesn't have to do all the
work?
Any thoughts on how to do that?
Huh.
A consensus protocol.
Y'all are jumping ahead.
Make all of them primaries.
Okay.
But that kind of brings us back to our
original problem, right? Of trying to
keep them consistent with each other. If
they're all primaries and the client can
read to all read from all of them and
write to all of them, then how are we
going to keep them consistent?
Now, I'm really glad that somebody
brought up consensus because it turns
out that this is what we're talking
about here is eventually going to lead
us to talking about consensus.
All right.
So,
we could have backups serve the reads,
right? We could have clients be able to
read from backups.
We could say,
client gets to make rights only to the
primary, but if they want to do a read,
they can talk to a backup. But if we do
that, then
we don't know what we'll be reading. We
might actually be reading data that's in
some sense from the future. So, that's
sort of what's happening here in this
messy, but hopefully somewhat intuitive
bottom picture here.
Um where the client is reading X, and
there's this right um where we where we
wrote um four before.
Uh but that right hasn't yet committed,
and we haven't heard anything back about
that right that second right committing
yet.
So,
if we're we were to do a read at this
point
from
a backup that already knew that X was
four, then our read would be reading
from the future in some sense. When we
read from the primary,
we know that we're either going to get
whatever um you know, whatever has been
acknowledged, right?
Well, let me propose an idea.
We could pick out a particular backup to
always read from.
And then
have that backup acknowledge us
when rights to the primary
have finished.
Let's look at what that would look like.
So, here's our client.
And we're going to keep it the same way
as before
where when we do a write,
it goes to
uh the primary.
So, maybe this is our
right of
set X to three.
And let's keep the same number of
replicas that we did before.
But let's have it work this way.
When we do a write,
instead of broadcasting it to everybody,
we're going to send it to
whichever replica is next.
Then that replica is going to send it to
whoever's next.
And then that replica is going to send
it to whoever's next.
And let's say that this one knows that
it's last.
So, now this one can acknowledge the
client.
In this setting, if the client wants to
do a read,
who are they going to read from?
That's right.
Reads are going to go to the last one in
the chain.
We just invented chain replication.
So, in chain replication, these
processes have particular names.
We call this one the head of the chain.
I'll call it H.
And then maybe you have some middle
nodes in the chain, middle links in the
chain. I'll call them M1 and M2.
And then this one's called the tail, so
T for tail.
So in chain replication,
you write to the head.
The head passes the right on to the next
link in the chain.
The next link of the chain keeps passing
it on and so on until you get to the
tail and then the tail acknowledges the
right to the client. So when the client
gets that acknowledgement, it knows that
since it's getting that act from the
tail,
it knows that
the right got to everybody.
So then,
reads can go to the tail.
So where's the commit point in this
picture?
That's right. The commit point's going
to be right here.
So the commit point in this case is
actually going to be on the tail.
So how are we doing on our goals of
fault tolerance and data locality and
dividing up work?
So we're still doing pretty well on
fault tolerance. We've still got lots of
copies.
Data locality,
eh,
we're not doing all that much better
than before.
We have a particular machine that's
going to that we're going to talk to
uh when we do writes
and we have a particular machine that
we're going to talk to when we do reads.
But that may or may not help so much
with data locality, right?
It depends where those machines are in
relation to us and what our balance of
rights and reads is. So
doesn't help so much with that.
What about dividing up the work?
It's a little bit better in that
respect.
So
instead of having all of the rights and
reads go to one
replica,
instead we're having the rights go to
one uh one replica and the reads go to
another.
So this is kind of nice, right? It
splits up the work in that respect.
So we're doing a little bit better on
dividing up the work.
Lots of good conversation in chat right
now.
So
there's a great question here.
How do these replicas know who's next in
the chain? Yeah. So
there had better be some way for the
replicas to know who's next,
right?
And there had better be a way for the
client to know who the head of the chain
is and who the tail is
because those are the ones that the
client is going to have to be talking
to.
So there's going to have to be some way
for everybody to know who's who. Of
course,
there's a similar problem with primary
backup, right?
The client is going to have to know who
the primary is that they're supposed to
talk to
and the primary is going to have to know
who all the backups are.
So
if a machine crashes, if a backup
crashes, the primary is going to have to
find that out somehow
so that doesn't wait forever to get an
acknowledgement from a crashed machine.
Oops.
There we go.
So with chain replication, we have this
problem, right? Where we have um we we
have to know who's who.
So the client has to know who the the
head of the tail is at who the who the
head and the tail are of the chain.
Every link in the chain has to know, you
know, who's before it and who's after
it. Or if you're the head, you have to
just know who's who's next, right? If
you're the tail, you just have to know
who's before you.
So these are important considerations
and we'll maybe talk a little bit more
about that in a second.
But let's talk about chain replication
and what its other
advantages are
over primary backup replication.
So chain replication is a relatively new
idea compared to primary backup.
Uh the paper came out in 2004.
So if you want to look it up on your
own,
it's called chain replication
for supporting
high throughput
and availability.
And the authors were uh
Robert Van Rennesse
and Fred Schneider.
Published it at OSDI, I think.
So it's interesting to look at this
title.
Uh what do you think they meant by this?
What's throughput?
Hm, so the suggestion in chat is you can
send a lot more write requests.
So what does this word throughput mean?
Let's define it.
So throughput,
we're going to say
number of actions per unit of time.
So in theory,
chain replication could give you better
throughput
than primary backup replication because
since we have one node that's handling
the writes and one node that's handling
the reads, then in theory at least, we
can handle more requests than if we just
had all of the nodes going through the
all of the reads and writes going
through the primary.
So depending on the mix of writes and
reads,
chain replication could do better than
primary backup replication in terms of
throughput.
So I'm going to say depending on the
workload,
and by workload I mean mix of writes
writes and reads,
chain replication
could give you better throughput.
What kind of a mix is good?
What would happen if you have
entirely reads?
Then is chain replication going to give
you any better throughput than primary
backup?
Yeah, so just to sketch out for you the
difference between the two.
If chain replication looks like this
for the write path
and like this
for the read path,
so that's chain replication.
And if primary backup looks like this
for the right path
and like this for the read path.
So, if everything's reads
it's not really going to make a
difference.
Will it?
Because in chain replication
all of the backups are going to that
same node, the tail node.
Or yeah, all the reads are going to the
tail. In primary backup, all the reads
are going to the primary. So,
if it's all reads
chain replication isn't going to help
you. What about if it's all writes?
Somebody suggested that primary backup
gives you faster
So, we're not we're not talking about
faster, right? We're we're talking about
here is throughput. We're talking about
number of actions per unit of time. So,
will primary backup let you do Let's say
you're doing entirely writes.
Is primary backup better in that
situation?
What do you think?
It's about the same.
So,
if you're if you have entirely writes,
chain replication doesn't really help
you. If you have entirely reads, chain
replication doesn't really help you.
When does chain replication help?
It's going to be when you have a mix
somewhere in the middle. So, yeah, the
suggestion in chat is when you have a
50/50 mix of reads and writes.
That seems intuitive. Like, it seems
like if you if you wanted to split up
the work nicely, then you would want
half of the work to go here and you'd
want half of the work to go here.
It turns out that a 50/50 split is not
quite right because it turns out that
reads are a bit more expensive to do
than than or sorry, writes are a bit
more expensive to do than reads.
So, if you have a 50/50 mix
you're still going to be doing more work
on the replica that's serving all the
writes
um than on the one that's serving all
the reads.
So, what you actually want
for optimal performance out of chain
replication, it turns out that you want
a mix that's like
maybe 15% writes
squiggle here because this is
approximate
85% reads.
It turns out that this sort of mix ends
up being optimal for chain replication.
So, if that's not intuitive for you,
just think about the fact that it takes
more effort uh
to deal with a write than it does to
deal with a read.
So, just you know for
argument's sake, let's take let's say
that it takes like three times more
effort to deal with a write uh than it
does with a read. Then,
if the workload is 15% writes and 85%
reads
but the writes take say three times more
effort
then you're going to be in a situation
where that split of 15% writes and 85%
reads
splits up the work more or less equally
between uh
between the head and the tail nodes.
So, something like this ends up being
more or less optimal. And you can look
it up in that paper that I mentioned and
they have some really nice experimental
results where they show different mixes
of reads and writes and how chain
replication performs compared to primary
backup under those mixes. Something like
this turned out to give you the most
advantage over primary backup in terms
of throughput.
What's the downside though of chain
replication?
We've been singing its praises, but
what's not so good about chain
replication? What do you think?
Well, some folks are talking about
crashes, right? Yeah, but that's also an
issue with primary backup replication.
Yeah, so certainly both of these
replication protocols have to do
something to deal with the problem of a
replica failing.
And that might be, you know, maybe a
little bit more involved to deal with if
it's chain replication because you have
to know, you know, who's in the chain
and if somebody fails somewhere in the
chain, then somebody has to be in charge
of figuring out that they failed and
maybe installing somebody new there and
so on. But you have similar challenges
with primary backup, it turns out. So,
that's not really a problem that's so
unique to to chain replication.
Uh there's a good suggestion in chat.
Has to do with latency. So,
what's latency? Let's just add it at the
top here, right here next to the
definition of throughput.
Does somebody want to define latency for
me?
What do you think the definition of
latency is?
Hm, units of time per per work.
Yeah, okay. I I kind of like that way of
putting it. That's kind of the flip side
of throughput.
Um yeah, I'm going to I'm going to
phrase it this way.
Time between
start
and end
of
one
action.
So,
latency as far as the client is
concerned, here's our client
is how long it takes to hear back
about a read or a write that they've
done. So, let's talk about read latency
first.
Is read latency going to be any
different for primary backup and and
chain replication as far as the client
is concerned?
So, this second
uh request down here, we're going to say
is the read. This top one is going to be
the write in both of these pictures.
So, how do these compare with each other
in terms of read latency?
Well,
either way, there's just two messages,
right? There's a request, there's a
response.
One one request, one response.
So, it looks about the same to me.
So, don't get confused by the fact that
in the Lamport diagram, this one happens
to be further away. So, that doesn't
mean that that machine is actually
further away from the client. It just
means physically further away. Um just
means that that's how we drew the
picture.
So, either way, there's just two
messages in terms of doing a doing a
read.
So, read latency is going to be about
the same whether you're doing chain
replication or primary backup.
What about write latency?
So, somebody made a really good comment
a little while ago in chat. They
mentioned parallelism. Yeah.
So, in primary backup
if the client does a write and it gets
to the primary
the primary is going to broadcast
that message at the same time
out to every one of these backups.
And these backups are going to process
that right in parallel
and acknowledge
the primary in parallel.
So, how long does the client have to
wait?
Well,
how many messages get sent? Well,
there's this first request, right? From
the client to the primary.
And then there's these two messages that
get sent out in parallel.
And then these two responses that get
sent again in parallel.
And then finally one more.
So, all the way around, it's going to be
four messages, right? It's going to be
the maximum
Now, whichever one of these is slower to
hit here.
So,
round trip of four messages.
What happened over here? Well, here
these messages
didn't get sent in parallel. We had to
wait for this message to get here and
then this message to get here.
So, instead of taking the maximum amount
of time for these two, we're actually
adding them together.
It still happens to be a round trip of
four in this picture, but what if I
added somebody else to the chain?
What if this one is the tail?
1 2 3 4 5. So, now I have a round trip
of five.
Whereas if I added another one over
here,
that wouldn't add any slowness, right?
It would just be
another request happening at the same
time as these other ones.
So, there's some parallelism here.
So, no matter how many I add here,
we're going to have a round trip of four
messages where the middle two messages
in the chain are going to be this this
uh
the slowest two in some sense. Whereas
here,
anytime we add replicas, which gives us
more fault tolerance, right? So, it
might be a nice thing to do in a lot of
situations.
Anytime we add replicas,
we're increasing the right latency.
So, like so many things in distributed
systems, it's a trade-off.
So,
so, I'm going to say CR has worse write
latency
than primary backup
depending on
how many
uh nodes are in the chain.
Questions about this?
I've already talked about this for much
longer than I had hoped to. So,
I want to wrap it up quickly.
But, I want to leave you with one last
thought. So,
in order for either of these replication
techniques to work,
the client has to know who to talk to,
right? In the case of primary backup,
they have to know who the primary is.
And in the case of chain replication,
they have to know who the head and the
tail are.
I guess I should fix this second picture
now that we added a new uh
tail node.
Also, the replicas themselves have to
know who's who. In the case of primary
backup, the backups have to know who to
ack, right? In the case of chain
replication, everybody has to know who's
ahead of them in the chain and and uh
who's behind them in the chain. So,
it's pretty important that everybody
agrees who's who. It would be very bad
if I thought that one machine was the
primary
and someone else thought that a
different machine was the primary. That
would definitely nuke our guarantee of
strong consistency that we were hoping
for. So, regardless of whether it's
primary backup or whether it's chain
replication,
either way, we come back to this problem
of agreement, of having to agree on
who's who.
And it's especially important because
from time to time machines are going to
fail and somebody else is going to have
to take over. And that's part of the
reason we're doing replication in the
first place.
So,
if a primary fails, then somebody is
going to have to be a in charge of
picking the new primary and making sure
everybody knows that's the new primary.
Likewise for chain replication,
there's going to have to be somebody who
tells clients who the current head and
tail are and somebody who knows who's
who in the chain.
And it turns out that in order to do
these things, uh you need to use some
sort of consensus protocol, which we're
going to talk about after the midterm.
So, that's a little bit of a preview of
where we're headed next in the course.
All right.
So,
let's do our 10-minute break. Let's do
our quiz and then after that, it's going
to be time for you to ask any questions
that you have.
So, let's see.
Here's today's quiz question.
And let's return at 4:25.
All right, see you in about 10 minutes.
What time did I say our break was going
to end?
Yeah, that's what I thought. Okay.
One more minute. One minute warning.
Right. Yeah, I heard he was recovering.
Okay.
It's 4:25, so let's jump back into it.
Welcome back.
Okay, so this time is for you all.
Uh it's for talking about anything that
you want to talk about in advance of the
exam.
Uh
so let's talk a little bit about the the
structure of the exam. So, it's going to
be
all of Thursday's uh class period.
The 95 minutes. Um
of course, if you have DRC
accommodations
um
then you have a
extension.
And it's going to cover cover everything
that we've talked about uh in these
first nine lectures. So, um just a
um
very quickly recap uh what that is, I
can bring up the schedule.
And I've updated our course web page so
that
the schedule now links to the videos
from uh the first eight lectures.
Obviously, the video link for this one
is not yet because uh
it hasn't happened yet.
But, um so here's our schedule on the
web page, and all these links go to the
videos. So, anything from lectures one
through today is going to be fair game
for the exam.
Uh is there anything on this list that
you would like us to talk about?
Okay.
Yeah, we can also do questions that have
to do with um with exam uh logistics
rather than the actual course content
material. Yeah, so um
some folks are asking about um
whether Canvas is going to spy on you
and you know, whether you whether you
leave the
um the exam page.
Uh
I find that the information that Canvas
provides on that sort of thing is um
is really not very helpful.
So,
um
I
I wouldn't tend to look at that stuff.
So, I I don't think it should be an
issue.
Okay, let's just start to write down
some of the things that folks are
suggesting here. Um I'll just try to
make a list of all of them, and then
we'll we'll try to um
uh go through them all. So, fault models
and fault classification.
Um
Can we cover definitions and jargon we
should know? Well,
can you be a little bit more specific on
any definitions or jargon that you don't
know? And then um or any anything that
you don't know the definition of, maybe
that you see on screen right now.
Um
Somebody wants a review of FIFO versus
causal
versus totally ordered delivery.
Um somebody else uh also wants an
example of total order.
Total orders and partial orders.
Uh delivery
in general.
Okay, maybe that can link up to this one
here.
Delivery versus receiving.
Okay, that might be enough for now.
So,
um
yeah, somebody just asked if the
material from today's lecture is going
to be on the midterm. Yep, it is.
All right, so let's let's look at fault
models. Um so, we looked at um
a bunch of different notions of of um
let's look at fault classification
first. So, we talked about a bunch of
different notions of
of of faults. So,
we talked about crash faults,
which are a subset of omission faults.
Oops.
Yeah, so here's I'm sorry about that. Um
so here's the list of things that I
wrote down. I don't think I got
everything that everybody listed, but
we'll see if we can get to these. Okay,
so
we'll start with fault fault
classification. So um
we talked about how crash faults are a
subset of omission faults and then how
those are a subset of Byzantine faults.
And this is a bit of a simplification.
There are further subdivisions that we
could do here, but let's just talk about
these as kind of the main ones. So
what is a crash fault?
Uh somebody want to remind me?
Yeah, so a crash fault is when a uh
when a process
uh stops
uh sending or receiving messages.
So as far as anybody else is concerned
uh
it's died.
It could be going along having internal
events, but no more sends and receives
are happening. So that's a crash fault.
We say that that these crash faults,
which
you know, we represent them on a Lamport
diagram usually by just putting an X.
This process crashed.
We say that crash faults are a subset of
omission faults.
And an omission fault is when
uh
a message
is lost.
So we say that crash faults are are a
subset of omission faults because
because crash faults are in some sense a
that's the special case of omission
faults
where all of the messages that are to or
from a particular process have been
lost. In other words, if you're going to
tolerate
uh omission faults, then you have to
also tolerate crash faults.
So that's why we have this nesting here
because tolerating omission faults means
that you are also obligated to tolerate
crash faults.
And then Byzantine faults?
This is when a a process behaves in an
arbitrary or malicious way.
And that's a super set of of both of
these because
a process that's behaving in an
arbitrary or malicious way could be
pretending to lose messages, right? Or
could be pretending to have crashed.
So
Byzantine faults encompass all of these.
If you're going to be tolerating if
you're going to claim to tolerate
Byzantine faults, then you're going to
also going to be obligated to tolerate
omission faults, which means you're
going to be obligated to tolerate crash
faults.
And then
when we speak of fault models, we mean
a sort of mental concept of reasoning
about
uh what faults can take place. So if
we're working within say the crash model
we're saying imagine a world where the
kinds of faults that can take place are
crash faults.
If we're talking about the omission
model, we're saying imagine a world
where the kinds of faults that can take
place are omission faults, which means
that also encompasses crash faults.
And if we're talking about the Byzantine
fault model, we're saying imagine a
world where all of these could happen.
So when you're designing a protocol or
an algorithm
one question to ask yourself is what
fault model are we assuming?
And then
you need to know that because that's how
you're going to those are that's going
to determine what kind of fault
tolerance you're going to have to
provide.
I think that about covers everything
that you might need to know for the exam
for this stuff. Um let's move on. So
let's talk about uh these delivery
guarantees.
So actually let's talk about delivery
versus receiving. So
couple people asked about this and this
is this is a pretty fundamental concept.
So
receiving a message
is something that happens to you.
You don't get to control when you
receive a message.
It just could happen at any time.
It's determined by
the network.
If somebody sends you a message
you could receive it
you know, maybe shortly after it's been
sent or maybe a long time after it's
been sent.
And that's going to depend on the
network and latency and you know,
whether it was lost and had to be resent
and you know, lots of other stuff. Um so
you don't get get to control when you
receive a message. That's something that
just happens to you um with arbitrary
timing.
Delivering a message
Oops.
This is what's done by
your mail clerk buddy
who's hanging out on a process
and deciding what to do with received
messages.
So delivering a message is a thing you
do
with a received message.
And I should say a thing you do or not
with a received message. So you could
choose not
to deliver a message that you've
received. Your mail clerk could get a
message and say
I don't want to deliver this message
yet.
Why would you do that? What would be the
point of not immediately delivering a
message? And what does it mean to
deliver a message? That means that
you're acknowledging that you've got it,
right? You're uh
if maybe if you're tracking
uh
the messages that you've received in a
vector clock, you know
your
at that point is is when your vector
clock gets incremented. Or if you have
some application that's supposed to get
these messages, then at that point you
hand the message off to the application.
So
it's when you deliver a message that you
record that you've gotten the message
and you hand it off to whoever it is
who's supposed to get it.
So
yeah, so the point of not immediately
delivering a message
maybe you're expecting another message
first.
So
that kind of leads us to this this
concept of um of FIFO delivery, right?
So
so a violation of FIFO delivery would be
if process one sends two messages to
process two
and they arrive and get delivered out of
order, that's a violation of FIFO
delivery or first in first out delivery.
To guard against that
the mail clerk on process two, when it
gets this message, this second message,
could do a number of things. They could
if these messages have sequence numbers
on them
process two could look at the sequence
number and say, oh, it looks like
there's still still some earlier message
that I'm waiting for from process one.
So I'm not going to deliver this one
yet. I'm going to hold off.
I'll put it in a queue.
And then bump it down here to get
delivered later.
So now this is no longer a FIFO
violation. Now this is delivery
that respects FIFO.
Likewise with causal delivery.
So here's our violation of causal
delivery, our classic violation of
causal delivery where we have
some messages that are being broadcast.
And this message here is going to arrive
over at at the third process
even though
this other message is supposed to
causally precede it. But how do we know
that this other message causally
precedes it? Because
the send
of this message
happens before the send of this message.
If you look at the happens before
relationship between those two message
sends.
So how would we guard against that?
Well, then once again, the mail clerk
sitting over here
would have to decide to queue this
message
and wait it to deliver it until later.
So now it now this picture is showing
causal delivery.
Now that we've delayed this message and
not delivered it in until the causally
preceding messages have been delivered
here on process three.
And there was also a question about
totally ordered delivery.
So we didn't talk about how to implement
totally ordered delivery yet. So we'll
just talk about uh
what it looks like to violate totally
ordered delivery.
So for that one recall we need four
processes. And my favorite way to talk
about this one is to say we have a
couple of clients
who are interacting with a key-value
store.
And maybe it's replicated. We've been
talking about replication today. So
let's say there are two replicas. And
let's say we're not doing one of these
nice things like primary backup or chain
replication that we talked about today.
Instead, let's just suppose the clients
are talking to whichever replica they
want.
Well,
let's say client one is talking to both
these replicas.
And so is client two.
And let's say that they're both writing
to the same key in the key-value store.
What happens here? Well,
replica one finds out that X is three,
then it finds out that X is four. So its
state ends up being this.
Replica two finds out that X is four,
then it finds out that X is three.
So these replicas end up disagreeing.
So the violation of totally ordered
delivery
uh is the way in which these messages
are being exchanged. It's not specific
to the key-value store example, but um
that's the example that I like to use to
make this uh little bit more real.
Um so this is a violation
of totally ordered delivery. We didn't
talk yet about how to fix this other
than just don't do this, right? We the
the one way that we've talked about for
fixing this is
don't have the client talk to more than
one replica. So that's what we talked
about today. We talked about a couple of
techniques for ensuring that uh
replicas stay consistent.
And we do it by having rights only go to
a particular replica. So
this couldn't happen under chain
replication or primary backup.
But it's not the
uh but that's not the whole story. So
that's something that we'll talk about a
lot more post-exam.
Okay. And somebody wanted to talk about
total orders
and partial orders.
Uh so these are mathematical concepts
that are useful to know because they
come up No, not only all the time in
distributed systems, but they come up
all the time in computer science.
So they're really, really good to know.
Um
So
our exa- our favorite example of a
partial order is the happens-before
relation.
Although that's a special one because
it's what we call an irreflexive partial
order.
So let's talk about what a partial order
is. I'll I'll get to total orders in a
second. Uh let's talk about what a
partial order is and then we'll talk
about why the happens-before relation is
special.
Um So a partial order is a set
um
together with
a binary relation
which you could write lots of different
ways. Maybe you write it like this,
maybe you write it like this.
In the case of partial order, it's an
arrow, but you use some notation for it.
Let's let's do this less than or equal
to notation. Um so this relation lets
you compare things from this set S.
And the relation has to be reflexive.
It has to be
antisymmetric
and transitive.
So reflexive means that
elements are related to themselves. So
if you have some A that's a member of
this set S,
A is related to A.
Antisymmetry
means that
if you have A and B that are members of
S, then
if A is related to B and B is related to
A,
then A and B are the same.
I'll write A equals B here to save
space.
Uh I know Ike would complain about that,
but um
just to save space, we're saying A
equals B. So
if the relation relates A to B and it
also relates B to A, then A and B have
to be the same. That's what antisymmetry
means. And then finally transitivity, if
you have
three elements that are all
members of this set S,
then
if A is related to B
and B is related to C,
then A is related to C.
So those are the properties that a
partial order is supposed to have.
Our favorite
partial order, the happens-before
relation is special. It's not
a partial order with all these
properties.
It lacks the reflexivity property. Why
does it re- lack the reflexivity
property? Uh because it would be really
weird for us to say that an event
happens before itself.
Because the the the happens-before
relation is a relation that relates
events, right? When we're talking about
happens before, we're talking about
relating one event to another.
And
reflexivity says that
things are related to themselves by the
relation. But
we couldn't say that A happens before A
or that B happens before B or that Q
happens before Q. That doesn't make any
sense. So the happens-before relation is
a special flavor of partial order that
we call irreflexive and that gives up on
this reflexivity property.
Total orders. How are total orders
different?
Anyone know?
I'm imagining people frantically looking
at Wikipedia right now.
We actually haven't talked all that much
about total orders, but they're
important, right? So what what's an
example of a total order? Well,
the events on a particular process
are totally ordered. Right?
If you have a bunch of events on one
process,
then those events have a total order.
There's We can't say that any of those
events are concurrent.
So
how can we express that mathematically?
So I'll give you a hint.
It's going to be all the same stuff
that's true about partial orders. So
reflexivity, antisymmetry, transitivity,
all those things are true.
But then there's going to be an extra
property.
I'll I'll even start to write it down
for you.
So if you have A and B
that are members of this set S, uh
what has to be true about A and B
if it's a total order?
Yep.
Good. Somebody just said it in chat. So
it's either going to be the case that
A is related to B
or
B is related to A.
Yep.
I guess I should write it with the same
notation I used before.
So, it's all the stuff about partial
orders. So, total orders are partial
orders plus this extra condition
where every pair of elements that's in
this set S has to be ordered by the by
the by the relation.
So, this isn't going to be the case for
all the events in a whole distributed
execution, right?
If we do like this,
you know, we look at all these events
here.
These events are no longer totally
ordered.
For example, A and E, those events don't
have an order. They happened on
different processes. So, we can't talk
about those events being total totally
ordered. We could only talk about the
events on a single process having a
total order here.
Make sense?
Uh so, somebody just asked, "What's the
difference What like why did I have to
add this um less than or equals instead
of less than here?" Well, so
that's actually this this irreflexive
thing. So, if I had just said this,
um that would be like an irreflexive
uh
order.
Um because this says um
this would be like the less than
relationship.
Um and A is not less than A. So, that
would be but
um
but we're not talking about that.
That's right. Yeah, so somebody just
asked, "Do all the members of the set
have to be comparable?"
Okay, we have 4 minutes left.
Um I'm going to see if we there was any
other uh questions about what we should
go over.
I think we covered a lot of the
important stuff just now. Um
Okay, so one person wanted to know a
little bit more about exam logistics.
Uh so, the exam will be on Canvas.
Uh it's going to have I think I think
right now it has a 18 questions. Uh you
have 95 minutes to do it. Um uh more if
you have some accommodation to get more
time.
Uh you can look at your notes. So, uh
let me bring up our um some information
about um
about uh
uh academic integrity on the exam. So,
as you all should know from having read
the course overview,
uh we have
a lot of information here about academic
integrity.
So, here's the section about academic
integrity on exams.
So, some of this stuff is going to be
quite obvious.
Um
you need to work alone on the exam.
Here's what you can use. So, you can use
your notes.
Um you can use the lecture videos. You
can use stuff that the course staff has
provided.
And you can look at materials that are
on the web freely available. So, it has
to be stuff that's findable with a web
search, not password protected.
Unless using those materials would
violate the the rule that you need to
work alone.
Here's the important thing that I really
want you to internalize.
You have to cite any sources that you
use. So, if you look something up,
cite it in your answer.
People have gotten in trouble here in
the past. Uh
so, in particular, something that people
folks do is, you know, sometimes, you
know, with no intention of wrongdoing,
they will copy and paste stuff from some
uh
source that they find online into their
notes as they're studying, but they fail
to quote it. So, they forget that it's
not their own words.
Then they put it right in the exam. So,
you might have noticed there are people
who put their notes from this course on
the web.
Um
that's totally reasonable thing for
people to do. So, you may have found
those. Um
but those are other people's words.
So,
if you're pointing to somebody's else if
you're pointing to somebody else's stuff
and using their words, that's a
violation of academic integrity.
You need to cite sources. You can't copy
and paste from the sources. You need to
use your own words, not theirs.
And then, of course,
you can't collaborate with people on the
exam or have outside help or use any
resources other than those. All this is
going to be uh
all this information that I've listed
here is going to be at the event the
beginning of the exam, too. And by
submitting the exam, you're going to
agree to this. Somebody just asked,
"Will you be able to go back to previous
questions?" Yes. So, when you get the
exam on Canvas, you'll be given all the
questions and you can order that you can
answer them in the order that you want
to order them.
Yeah, if you use something if you use
some external source, um
if you need to look something up in
order to answer a question
from some external source, you need to
cite it.
Okay, there was just a question.
"Will citing somebody's notes found
online be a violation of academic
integrity if the answers are written in
our own words?"
Um
no, that's okay to do.
"MLA format?"
We will not take points off on the exam
for improper formatting of your
citations.
All right.
Uh it's 4:55,
but I don't want to um
I I don't want to deprive anybody of a
chance to discuss exam-related stuff.
So, um I got a question privately about
um about Chandy Lamport and somebody
wanting to go over that. Um we're out of
time for today, unfortunately, but um
I'm happy to talk about it in office
hours. So, um feel free to come talk to
me or just um ask questions on Zulip and
I'll do my best to get to them.
Right.
Let's wrap up for today.
And good luck on the exam.